one cop goes too far and now we're all
guilty Larsen is just this month's
victim you are a police officer that's
dealing with racial injustice did you
start empathizing a little bit for our
men in blue after playing this role I
did about a month of ride alongs and
those were sleepless nights for me and I
was sort of ashamed of myself having
this one perspective one side one side
of looking at it I was then I started
thinking about how ugly we as a people
are you know and just like you know
there's a lot of people that are wrong
you know that are not doing their jobs
right or that deserve to be put in jail
you know so I it was it was hard to know
how to feel because those so I was it
was there was so much going on but that
service the character that's exactly
what I needed to feel for Dennis John
David Washington nailed his role as a
cop in Monsters and Men a character his
dad did Zell also channeled in training
day no no no we're not racking up
arrested a now John David might be ready
to follow in his parents footsteps on
the big stage your parents have had
massive success as well have you thought
about jumping in to Broadway and what
tips do you have for him not a musical
but I mean I would love to go on stage
right now I'd love to see both of you
guys together you see three minutes of a
shaky video and you think you know what
you do we're seeing this or three
different perspectives of a police
shooting can you talk to me about three
different men in your life that have
been pivotal to your life story Wow
question
my brother there's a guy he was my high
school mentor his name was uh his name
is Jason Jacobs he was he was like my he
was my my counsellor in high school I
was going through a lot and and I wasn't
too ashamed to get help in high school
and he was there and he's still one of
my mentors to this day and now I've got
like a later on in my life now recently
I've gained another mentor his name is
Pat Richie really good friend of mine
and Pat is I called him before every big
decision in my life you gotta have that
one for every big decision I call her
you know
yeah III think about my cousin Rick
Weaver think about my uncle this is his
necklace he's not going no longer with
us
uncle Woodson who was the ultimate
communicator he added like he had this
sudden like cadence and stutter but he
but he was very clear about his family
yeah you know he knew that he had this
uncanny ability to communicate and
express love and his as a man I could
cut grass chop the wood give you a hug
and tell you loves you you know so it
was very manly in one way but he's very
in touch with his of his feelings and
you had expressed them and you know I
every time I go out there I when I say
go out there but I hit the field when I
play football or I'll do a scene and I
get ready for a film you know I take
this with me I think about him all the
time those are some really touching
stories and we have to have the you know
that village that we can go to raise
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]